if you want to prove what things rather
than another okay
the easiest way even though it seems
there's not much difference here alright
the easiest way to prove that one thing
is greater than another is to prove that
if you take this difference the
difference will be positive okay
now you're like algebraically what did
we just do I just subtracted B from both
sides it's like no big deal right
but what does this mean geometrically
let me think about it by pretty amazing
put a number on it okay now if you got
like you know zero C negatives and
positives okay I want to prove that hey
is B right
another way of saying that is it a is to
the right of B okay now what you are
taking a difference when you're
subtracting right the order batters
which one you subtract from the other
right because a minus B minus a I'm not
the same thing okay so to rephrase this
instead of saying algebraically these
are both algebraic statements which I'm
totally equivalent to prove that I'm
gonna say it geometrically that a is to
the right of being
okay haze to the right okay how would
you how would you word this geometric
would come in okay now think of it as
carefully with me if this is the
geometric meaning of this algebraic
inequality how would you put into a
sentence is it equality how would you
know that's true but you still speaking
algebraically you're still speaking out
draping I'm trying to think in terms of
left and right way to say it but then
again I could have the other way that's
that's saying that's not really
translation of business of it it's kind
of like now I'm introducing lots and
lots of sentences which are each
individually equivalent to bits
yeah yeah this is coming back to he's
the way I would say it okay a minus B
what does it represent it represents a
distance okay it represents how far I
have to go from B to a not vice-versa
like that it's the distance from B to a
okay so I'm going to say the distance
from B to a right
that distance is positive that's what
I'm gonna say okay how can be negative
because if I go if I have to go the
other way right from B to a if I have to
go from B to say minus one okay now see
I'm trying to get in terms of lesson
right here right I'm going to the left
right well I could say I have to travel
right after how much to the right to get
from B to a
okay now the reason why it's a it's more
in our interests right to say things
like this than this okay is that it's
actually quite easy to prove that things
are greater than zero okay we know all
kinds of properties it'll help us and
the most important one is swearing okay
so what I can say is if I have some kind
of squaring it's very not not course
language by the way the verb of squared
square root is a is a noun and the verb
of square root is taking the square root
square if I can establish that something
is squared then I can say that it's
greater equal 0 right and furthermore if
I already know that I'm a isn't equal to
0 okay then I can say that unequivocally
it must be positive when I square it
we're gonna use that make sense because
the only way and I'm actually going to
introduce a weird little bit of notation
here um the only way that I can get the
Equality right if I can reach the
boundary for 0 okay is if and only if a
0 okay so there's a short form for this
if it really if is um
turns out to be I really really comments
david inequality okay so it means if and
this is the only way it could possibly
happen right if it only if equals zero
so the shorthand for this is if with an
extra F on the end yeah yeah that's
right that's right okay because it's
about logic logic do you mean so
that boundary right yes yes so this is
this is the opposite case right this is
the opposite case okay so I can only hit
the battery if I if I had that specific
matter